buenos días un saludo cordial yo creo
que el país está viviendo una época de
profunda fragmentación polarizada esto
que quiere decir que hemos vivido el
correísmo anti correísmo y las fuerzas
distintas que en el país son 10 283
partidos políticos reconocidos se han
alineado en esas dos perspectivas pero
en estos resultados electorales
lo que hemos visto es una situación
distinta se votó casi la tercera parte
de la población por el lazo 35 por
ciento la tercera parte por araus 32 por
ciento y la tercera parte votos blancos
y votos nulos yo creo que la tesis que
ha planteado el presidente electo lazo
de buscar la unidad nacional de buscar
el reencuentro es absolutamente
necesaria para el país porque además el
país está fragmentado territorialmente
la sierra votó mayoritariamente por lazo
y la costa absolutamente por zarautz
bueno pero la economía y la pandemia son
los principales retos del lazo en este
momento y el nuevo presidente ha
prometido vacunar a 9 millones de
personas en 100 días y acabar con el
déficit fiscal en 4 años sin embargo
deberá gobernar cuando el correísmo
cuenta con la mayor bancada en la
asamblea como valorar las o sacar
adelante sus objetivos en este panorama
político polarizado el reto que él mismo
ha planteado este de la unidad del
reencuentro tiene que tener su contra
para su contraparte básicamente en
políticas pero aquí tiene un problema
adicional que es exactamente lo que se
plantea una asamblea también fraccionada
tenemos de la fuerza
dt ar austral correísmo 48 votos de ya q
pérez de pachakutik
27 votos de la izquierda democrática 18
de lazo 12 y del partido socialcristiano
18 como reconstruir rezo a partir de una
propuesta de una agenda legislativa es
un gran reto en otras palabras no sólo
es plantearle al país en general sino
también gobernar
y establecer grandes acuerdos con el
sistema parlamentario y aquí los grandes
problemas que tiene el país es uno la
economía dos la salud y tres toda la
cuestión social vinculada al empleo y a
la violencia
bueno y además ecuador enfrenta una
situación fiscal compleja con una deuda
que bordea el 70% del producto interno
bruto y una economía dolarizada que le
impide emitir moneda como serán las
relaciones del nuevo gobierno con los
organismos como por ejemplo el fondo
monetario internacional que debe hacer
lazo para recuperar la economía y al
tiempo evitar nuevos estallidos sociales
por medidas que pueden resultar muy
impopulares
sí ese es uno de los grandes retos el
manejo de la economía que es una deuda
externa muy alta un déficit fiscal muy
muy fuerte una contracción de la oferta
que no se ha visto en la historia una
incapacidad de la demanda para el
consumo un comercio externo
absolutamente desequilibrado y ahí tiene
que trabajar ahora buenas noticias para
el ecuador los resultados electorales
que se obtuvieron este día domingo hizo
que el riesgo país caiga sustancialmente
eso significa que al menos en términos
internacionales las capacidades de
renegociación que exista con lo que se
denominan los bonistas es decir las
personas y las instituciones que tienen
bonos así como la banca multilateral
pueden ser muchos pueden estar mucho
mejores condiciones de las que estaba
por lo menos el gobierno que está a
punto de fenecer